I do think that CEO behavior has
improved at least on the margin if not
more so we haven't seen you know it's
funny for all of the financial
destruction and the markets that are
taking place you know this this has been
a period where we have not seen people
get get taken away in handcuffs whether
it be on Wall Street or elsewhere you
know occasionally you hear about an
insider trading ring or you know a
one-off usually some mom and pop in
Czechoslovakia that seemed to get you
know taking over taken away but you
haven't heard of a big-time CEOs in a
lot of trouble and I do think that one
of the one of the things that was going
on during the Enron period and why
prosecutors were as harsh as they
weren't I know a lot of people thought
they were too harsh was that they were
really thinking about the deterrence
factor and at least so far we talked
about short memories on Wall Street at
least so far it's working as I said
before everything comes in cycles and I
can't imagine we won't do this all again
anyway
you